so today Amazon announced fire TV it's  their streaming video device it's going  to compete with Apple TV and Roku I  wanted to find out a little bit more  about it so I went to fire tv.com and  what I discovered was actually something  kind of interesting on fire TV com is a  streaming video site it has more than 17  thousand titles it just so happens that  most of those titles have names like  stick it to the ma'am and [ __ ] and  [ __ ] you see fire tv.com is a porn  site actually has been one for quite  some time or so I have been told now  what this means for the site is unclear  amazon may decide to let it continue  existing and pretend that it never  happened or they may want that name for  themselves in which case those fine  young gentlemen running fire tv.com may  have just run into a wind farm